desde que estalló la revolución libia
inspirada por las oleadas de movilizaciones masivas
tanto de la revolución tunecina como de la egipcia.
Uní fuerzas con muchos otros ciudadanos libios, dentro y fuera del país
para llamar a un día de furia
e iniciar una revolución contra el régimen tiránico de Gaddafi.
Y lo logramos; fue una gran revolución.
Mujeres y hombres jóvenes libios estaban en la vanguardia,
exigiendo la caída del régimen,
portando pancartas de libertad, dignidad y justicia social.
Han mostrado una valentía ejemplar
al enfrentar la brutal dictadura de Gaddafi.
Han mostrado un gran sentido de solidaridad
desde el Extremo Oriente, hasta el oeste, hasta el sur.
Finalmente, después de un período de seis meses de guerra brutal
y unas pérdidas de aproximadamente 50 mil muertos,
logramos liberar nuestro país y derrocar al tirano.
(Aplausos)
Sin embargo, Gaddafi dejó una pesada carga,
un legado de tiranía, corrupción y semillas de alteración.
Durante cuatro décadas, el régimen tiránico de Gaddafi
destruyó la infraestructura, la cultura y la estructura moral de la sociedad libia.
Consciente de la devastación y de los desafíos,
he querido, junto a muchas otras mujeres, reconstruir la sociedad civil libia,
exigiendo una transición inclusiva y justa
hacia la democracia y la reconciliación nacional.
Se establecieron aproximadamente 200 organizaciones en Bengasi
durante, e inmediatamente después de la caída de Gaddafi.
Aproximadamente 300 en Tripoli.
Después de un periodo de 33 años de exilio, volví a Libia
y con un entusiasmo único,
comencé a organizar talleres
sobre el desarrollo de capacidades, y habilidades de liderazgo.
Con un increíble grupo de mujeres
fundamos la Plataforma de Mujeres Libias por la Paz,
un movimiento de mujeres, líderes, de orientación muy diversa,
para abogar por la autonomía sociopolítica de la mujer
y por nuestro derecho
de participación igualitaria en la construcción de la democracia y la paz.
Me encontré con un entorno muy difícil en el periodo pre-electoral;
un ambiente que estaba cada vez más polarizado,
que se modeló de las políticas egoístas de dominación y exclusión.
Lideré una iniciativa a través de la Plataforma de Mujeres Libias por la Paz,
para abogar por una ley electoral más incluyente,
una ley que le diera a cada ciudadano, sin importar su origen,
el derecho de votar y presentarse en las elecciones,
y lo más importante, estipular en los partidos políticos
la alternación de los candidatos y candidatas
vertical y horizontalmente en sus listas,
creando la "lista cremallera".
Con el tiempo, nuestra iniciativa fue aprobada y exitosa.
Las mujeres ganaron un 17,5% del Congreso Nacional
en las primeras elecciones en 52 años.
(Aplausos)
Sin embargo, poco a poco, la euforia de las elecciones
y la revolución como un todo,
fueron desapareciendo;
todos los días encontrábamos noticias de violencia.
Un día nos despertamos con la noticia
de la profanación de mezquitas antiguas y tumbas sufíes.
Otro día amaneció con la noticia
del asesinato del embajador estadounidense y el ataque al consulado.
Otro día nos despertamos con la noticia
del asesinato de oficiales del ejército.
Y cada día, cada día nos despertamos con el gobierno de las milicias
y sus continuas violaciones de los derechos humanos de los presos
y su falta de respeto de la ley.
Nuestra sociedad, formada por una mentalidad revolucionaria,
se polarizó más,
y se ha alejado de los ideales y principios de
libertad, dignidad, justicia social,
que teníamos al principio.
La intolerancia, la exclusión y la venganza
se convirtieron en los íconos de las consecuencias de la revolución.
No estoy aquí hoy en absoluto para inspirarlos
con nuestra historia del éxito de la "lista cremallera" y las elecciones.
Más bien estoy aquí hoy para confesar
que nosotros, como nación, elegimos mal, tomamos la decisión equivocada,
no priorizamos bien.
Porque las elecciones no trajeron la paz, la estabilidad y la seguridad a Libia.
¿La lista cremallera y la alternación entre candidatos y candidatas
trajeron paz y reconciliación nacional?
No, no lo hicieron.
¿Qué pasó entonces?
¿Por qué nuestra sociedad sigue polarizada y dominada
con políticas egoístas de dominación y exclusión, tanto por hombres como por mujeres?
Tal vez lo que faltaba no eran solo las mujeres,
sino los valores femeninos de compasión, misericordia e inclusión.
Nuestra sociedad necesita el diálogo nacional y la creación de consenso
más de lo que necesitaba las elecciones,
que solo reforzaron la polarización y la división.
Nuestra nación necesita la representación cualitativa de lo femenino
más que necesitar la representación numérica y cuantitativa de ello.
Necesitamos dejar de actuar como agentes de indignación y llamar a días de ira.
Necesitamos comenzar a actuar como agentes de compasión y misericordia.
Tenemos que desarrollar un discurso femenino,
que no solo honre, sino también ponga en práctica
la misericordia en lugar de la venganza, la colaboración en lugar de la competencia,
la inclusión en lugar de la exclusión.
Estos son los ideales que una Libia, destrozada por la guerra,
necesita desesperadamente con el fin de alcanzar la paz.
Porque la paz tiene una alquimia
que trata de la interrelación y la alternación
entre las perspectivas femeninas y las masculinas.
Esa es la verdadera cremallera.
Necesitamos establecer aquello de una manera existencial
antes de hacerlo de forma sociopolítica.
De acuerdo con un versículo del Corán
"Salam"--la paz-- "es la palabra del Dios misericordioso, [rajeem, compasivo]".
A la vez, la palabra "raheem", que se conoce en todas las tradiciones abrahámicas,
tiene la misma raíz en árabe que la palabra "rahem"--útero--,
simbolizando lo femenino y maternal, que abarca a toda la humanidad
de la que hombres y mujeres,
de la que todas las tribus y todos los pueblos han emanado.
Y así, al igual que el útero cubre completamente el embrión, que crece dentro,
la matriz divina de la compasión nutre toda la existencia.
Así se nos dice: "Mi misericordia abarca todas las cosas".
Así se nos dice: "Mi misericordia prevalece sobre mi ira".
Que a todos se les conceda la gracia de la misericordia.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.